this is a straight que method question
you are asked to find any question
that's a line rather that's concurrent
with the Institute so pass it through
their points interception and also
passes through this so in other words
your situation something like this are
one of these lines would like X plus 3y
equals blows and something like that
right so you want a line that goes
through there that point of detection
but also goes through something like
that so that's the line you're on top
that's where we're headed so you don't
need to draw that picture I just want
you to understand what you're trying to
find so how do I go about this to use
the que method
you call this line one you call this
line two and you need to get that in
general for conservatives came up in
secret right which is already in general
form but let this one I just have to
subtract twice both sides that'll make
this zero I only came where the zero is
sold as well as I'm to zero so if I say
X plus sine X minus y plus three equals
zero at risk oh okay that's all I need
so I'm going to say l1 plus KL to equal
zero
that's became a hood right and now I
just kind of started one through it
so I'm going to say l1 look like this I
need to write that right yeah yeah put
it right there no one he comes up to it
being equal to zero okay now at this
point here I think Spencer I can expand
I can also take a value three two and I
can trust you in to buy my value of K
all right so I'm the business point I
think I usually expand but let me show
you you can do it it doesn't really
matter I'm going to substitute you three
two
watch
there's the 3s and then too okay so I'm
going to get three take away two and
three Austin are you happy with my
substitution to the look okay no yeah
what's this going to be equal to that's
just 6 minus 2 which is 4
I'm going to cut that and subtract it
from both sides and then this is just
going to be totally off okay okay okay
look good now having found a value okay
having used this point I can now bring
that back to the equation I already used
a third line I can just substitute it in
X minus one plus three plus the piece
like that okay um this is pretty routine
from here usually among the current
membership that this usually you'd be us
to provide this back in general or
usually so being it whatever things that
general form is if I zero on the right
hand side that looks good what else you
to our general that will be informed by
next step what else
you're fools of us all the waitresses so
there's one teeny thing that will cause
the conference with my whole numbers
daily the value of care that I just
found easy to get rid of that the
denominator is five so while I do well
by really by five so let's do this I
might as well explain spenders going
while I'm at it what's this going to be
I multiplied by five so the odom of five
is no longer there yes so minus four X
minus four one and then I'm going to
collect like terms conveniently it looks
like I still have a positive values than
a but I don't need to do any more really
just collect so I'm going to get X minus
9y equals you happy just as a quick note
as a sense check because I did just what
I did draw this write X minus 9y plus 15
that's going to be 9 y equals x plus 15
so that this 15 over nine is one and six
ninths which is 1 and 2/3 that be
flaking but a nice it's nice and gentle
and yeah that looks like it could be
wanted to dress so even my shadow
diagram props to serve to confirm the
numbers where that ended up ok take this
situation remember you provided with
three pieces of information to the unis
who provided with equations of two lines
and then you are provided with a point
okay by the way a quick little
interesting thing you're provided with
three pieces of information the three
pieces informations corresponds to the
fact that you're finding three nodes a X
of B Y plus CB needs three numbers right
now you don't have to just be provided
with this you can also be provided with
a grain because if you think about it
come back to our original diagram which
is why you're so helpful
right instead of being provided a point
that your line was passed to if you know
that your third and final line is going
with me soon there's only a single one
which had a specific rate if I ask for
us to be gradient I should be able to
find the one unique way that passes
through my bikes intersection point and
also has that gradient so let's just
play never leave now I'm just going to
pick this alley because I know it's the
one that we can jump in before so we can
confirm whether we get all the right
numbers that we expect
so just the questions for the last two
minutes
I'm putting the question in anyway same
two buttons but instead of finding the
third line which goes through here I
want a third line which has this exact
rating how do I do it well the first
thing to note is I can still use came
with it because still the same scenario
okay
so I'm still going to do this and then
I'm still I should say with red I'm
still going to substitute even get this
okay but at this point now well I can't
do this can i because I don't have a
point to sub it okay instead I'm trying
to get to what a gradient so what can I
do instead what I do anything okay I can
expand this this is why I avoided last
but I still can do this right the reason
why I want to get this guy this
disastrous mess into a form that helps
me see where this is okay so this is
something close the general form right
now is incentive actually if I were to
factorize it would be I don't want your
father chair a4 makes it hard to see
brainian what might be a good choice
why would there especially that'll be a
good place to go so I'm going to take
this guy here let's expand those
brackets just need to go here you got to
get KX plus KY
okay now in order to get to y equals MX
plus B form right the defining thing
about it is the left hand side it's just
why right so I want to make one subject
what will I do to this to get towards
making one subject well it's how about
gave the wires all by themselves
okay so I can see and the y term here
one term there that all the lines and
I'm going to get rid of everything else
over the other side okay so it looks
like I've got a candy Y minus y equals
those are all positives
how do you do that look okay yeah
I know to do this but I love the way
right I go to leave why terms over here
on the left
what can I do down to get closer to
having just the why Toronto okay good so
when I factorize out the way that these
is I'm going to rewire this like this do
you see why I did I see why my do that
for why does it help me because then I
can because I'm going to MX plus B form
so not only is the Y or tone there's a
single X term on the right hand side
that's what I want okay so in a bitter
word divided by K minus one in a minute
but over here have a look what do you
got here if i factor out the X what its
left below into -1 there and uh minus K
and then this must retain out of it so
finite a contract with minus one one oh
you'll see in a second
I then I wanted to divide through by
this K minus one is that okay because
now I have Y on its own okay
now I'm almost there almost there what
is M what is that it's the coefficient
of x here is this guy okay
it is a slightly messy form at the
moment I got asked before why not
factoring out the negative one I want to
try it out the negative one but easy and
out of this guy is here right because
factoring out a negative 1 from here is
the same as switching the order of this
become 1 minus K so therefore I can
conclude n is equal to 1 plus K or one
lasers K you okay with that
you see I took a negative 1 out of top
such with a negative 1 out of the water
but what is this thing
apparently it good night yeah so why do
you know when it cost multiply it's
slightly messy but we can do this this
is going to be 9 plus 2 okay so now what
I'm going to add K to this side which
will give me 10 K and then I'm going to
subtract 9 from the other side or from
both sides rather which will give me
negative 8
yeah now what divide by 10 which 8 10
common factor namely to which
surprise-surprise gives me this are you
happy of course we end up this number
because I chose the gradient that the
original one is that with so now you
would proceed just like you did before
and you can put you back in your place
okay